this is just fantasy  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  from reality  [Music]  I enjoyed the show I also write songs  lead sing it is quick and then gonna  need someone new another we move upstage  grimm belongs to you can you see what  you could be  no one will play us on the radio we need  to get experiments do it again how many  more Galileo's do you want Roger there's  only room in this band for one  hysterical Queen Matt these words no one  will play free fortune favors the bold  Freddie concerning your private life  what more do you need to know I make  music I want to give the audience a song  that they can perform what's the lyric  ready Freddy that's good  [Music]  you need to slow down Fred I just need a  bit of time but if I don't have time  [Music]  [Music]  you're alleging the first we're all  legends  [Applause]  you